So, the answer to this question should be, the
middle three children should be shaded in as affected. Now
think about this for a second if you had trouble;
maternal inheritance means it can only be inherited from the
mother. Why is that? You only get mitochondria from the
mother. So, in this case the affected mother and unaffected
father all of the children were affected. Both the males
and the females, because they all got their mitochondria from
the mother. So in this case over here the male
is affected. Great. So now he's going to have his
own three children, but does he pass mitochondria down to
children? No, he doesn't. Only the mother does that, so they
wouldn't be affected. Same thing over here. Male was affected
but he doesn't pass his mitochondria down. The mother was unaffected
in these cases so they'g going to be unaffected children
for this particular trait. On the other hand the females in
this row were effected and since they passed their mitochondria down
to the next generation all their children are affected as well